>> Geraldo: THE CO-STARS OF
WILL AND GRACE TAKING ON
TRUMP SUPPORTERS DEBRA
MESSING AND ERIC MCCORMICK
THE LATEST TO FACE FIERCE
BACKLASH AFTER NAMES OF
THOSE IN HOLLYWOOD WHO WILL
BE ATTENDING AN UPCOMING
TRUMP FUNDRAISER TO BE
OUTED.
JUST THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF
THOSE ON THE LEFT TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE THE PRESIDENT'S
BACKERS.
THE TWO ACTORS BEING
CRITICIZED EVEN BY FELLOW
CELEBRITIES.
"THE VIEW" CO-HOST WHOOPI
GOLDBERG HAS STRONG WORDS.
WHOOPI.
>> YOUR IDEA OF WHO YOU
DON'T WANT TO WORK WITH IS
YOUR PERSONAL BUSINESS.
DO NOT ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
PRINT OUT LISTS BECAUSE THE
NEXT LIST THAT COMES OUT
YOUR NAME WILL BE ON AND
THEN PEOPLE WILL BE COMING
AFTER YOU.
IN THIS COUNTRY, PEOPLE CAN
VOTE FOR WHO THEY WANT TO,
THAT IS ONE OF THE GREAT
RIGHTS OF THIS COUNTRY.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LIKE IT.
[APPLAUSE]
BUT YOU -- WE DON'T GO AFTER
PEOPLE BECAUSE WE DON'T LIKE
WHO THEY VOTED FOR.
WE DON'T GO AFTER THEM THAT
WAY.
WE CAN TALK ABOUT ISSUES AND
STUFF, BUT WE DON'T PRINT
OUT LISTS.
>> Brian: BRAVO WHOOPI.
>> Geraldo: KATIE, THEY
REMINDS ME OF THE CASTRO
BROTHERS.
JOAQUIN THE BROTHER OF
JULIAN THE PRESIDENT
CANDIDATE OUTING ALL THE
TRUMP SUPPORTERS IN SAN
ANTONIO.
>> Katie: WASN'T JUST TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
OUTING THE TRUMP SUPPORTERS
ON THE LIST CASTRO
SUPPORTERS AS WELL WHO HAD
GIVEN DONATIONS TO HIM.
>> Brian: THE WHOLE THING
BLEW UP.
>> Katie: REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS BASED ON THEIR
RIGHT TO DO SO AND, YET, IT
BACKFIRED.
WHEN DEBRA MESSING CALLS FOR
THE LIST OF TRUMP SUPPORTERS
TO BE RELEASED, SHE IS NOT
DOING IT FOR THE GOOD OF THE
COUNTRY, FOR SOME GOOD
CAUSE.
SHE IS DOING IT SO THESE
PEOPLE IN HOLLYWOOD CAN'T
WORK AGAIN.
THERE IS AN UNDERGROUND
MOVEMENT IN HOLLYWOOD IT'S
BEEN THERE FOR 30 YEARS
ABOUT CONSERVATIVES WHO WORK
IN HOLLYWOOD STAY QUIET AND
DO THEIR JOBS.
THEY CAN'T COME OUT PUBLICLY
AND TALK ABOUT POLITICS EVEN
THOUGH YOU SEE IT AT AWARDS
SHOW AND LEFT IS ALLOWED TO
TALK ABOUT IT WHENEVER THEY
WANT AND SHOVE IT DOWN YOUR
THROAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO HAVING A
DIFFERENT POINT OF VIEW,
HOLLYWOOD ACTRESSES LIKE
DEBRA MESSING AND PEOPLE
HAVE A LOT MORE CREDIBILITY
AND POWER THAN SHE DOES IN
HOLLYWOOD THINK YOU SHOULD
BELIEVE IN LEFTISM, YOU HAVE
A MONOLITHIC THOUGHT
PROCESS.
IF YOU DON'T WE ARE GOING TO
HARASS YOU AND PRINT YOUR
PHONE NUMBER AND ADDRESS AND
YOUR FAMILY WILL BE HARASSED
AND YOU WILL NEVER WORK A
DAY AGAIN.
THAT'S WHY SHE IS DOING IT
AND DISGRACEFUL.
WHOOPI GOLDBERG STOOD UP FOR
THEM.
GOOD ON HER.
RELEASING LISTS OF NAMES
USUALLY GOES ONEWAY.
IT'S THE LEFT CALLING FOR IT
TO BE RELEASED ON THE RIGHT.
YOU NEVER KNOW, THESE PEOPLE
MAY SUPPORT BOTH PARTIES
AND, YET, YOU STILL WANT TO
OUT THEM AS TRUMP SUPPORTERS
AND PUNISH THEM FOR THEIR
THOUGHTS, THE THOUGHT POLICE
ESSENTIALLY.
>> Geraldo: THIS IS THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF THE
MCCARTHY ERA.
IN THOSE DAYS THE RIGHT WING
WAS PERSECUTING THE LEFT
WING AND NOW IT'S THE OTHER
WAY AROUND.
IT'S STILL STINKS.
>> Jesse: HOW IGNORANT
HOLLYWOOD ACTRESS CALLING
FOR SOMEONE TO BE
BLACKLISTED.
DOLLS SHE NOT KNOW THE
HISTORY OF HER OWN COUNTRY
AND INDUSTRY?
SHE PUT OUT A TWEET AND SAYS
WE NEED TO COME TOGETHER.
LET'S TALK.
LET'S REALLY TALK.
AND SHE PUT OUT A PHONE
NUMBER.
SO I'M GOING TO CALL THE
PHONE NUMBER AND I'M JUST
GOING TO TRY TO TALK TO HER
AND SHE WHAT SHE SAYS.
SHALL I CALL THE NUMBER
RIGHT NOW?
LET'S CALL IT RIGHT NOW.
WE WILL PUT IT ON SPEAKER
PHONE.
>> Brian: ASK HER IF SHE IS
OUT THERE IN THE HURRICANE.
>> Jesse: CALL HER AND SEE
WHAT SHE HAS TO SAY.
YOU CAN'T SAY YOU WANT TO
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER AND
BLACKLIST PEOPLE BECAUSE
THAT JUST HURTS THEIR
FAMILIES, THAT HURTS THE
ENTIRE INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE YOU ARE GOING TO
DEPRIVE HOLLYWOOD AND ALL
THE AUDIENCES OF.
>> HI THERE, IT'S DEBRA.
YEP, THAT'S RIGHT.
IT'S ME.
I AM NOT GOING TO BE
LISTENING TO THIS BECAUSE I
AM ONLY GOING TO BE READING
YOUR TEXTS.
SO, PLEASE TEXT ME.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: THAT'S NOT
TALKING.
I FEEL LIKE SHE HAS ALREADY
BEEN BLACKLISTED.
I HAVEN'T SEEN HER IN YEARS.
>> Brian: SHE IS DEFINITELY
TALENTED AND WILL AND GRACE
WAS A GOOD SHOW.
I DON'T THINK THE REMAKE IS
HAVING THE SAME SUCCESS.
WE WERE JUST GOING OVER SOME
ROUGH LIST OF CELEBRITIES
THAT WOULD BE GOING TO THE
DONALD TRUMP EVENT.
OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE WITH MONEY
OR ELSE THEY WOULDN'T GO TO
BEVERLY HILLS.
KELSEY GRAMMER, DEAN CAIN,
JOIN VOIGHT.
>> THAT'S ABOUT IT.
>> Brian: THE CREATOR OF THE
ADIS.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK BURNETT.
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS IS THE
ONE THING, GERALDO, I WILL
TAKE A PAGE FROM YOUR BOOK.
DONALD TRUMP IN THIS
CAMPAIGN SHOULD BE GOING TO
AREAS THAT DISAGREE WITH HIM
AND HAVING THIS DEBATE THE
WAY JOHN MCCAIN DID, AND
THIS IS THE BEGINNING.
THIS IS SAYING DON'T BOTHER,
IT'S NOT WORTH IT.
AND I WANT HIM TO GO TO
BEVERLY HILLS.
I WANT HIM TO GO TO CHICAGO.
I WANT HIM TO GO TO THOSE
PLACES NOT JUST PLACES THAT
LOVE HIM.
AND MAKE CHALLENGE --
CHALLENGE PEOPLE TO
CHALLENGE HIM.
>> Katie: HE ALWAYS JOKES
ABOUT HE HAD A CAMPAIGN IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE HE WOULD
HAVE.
>> Geraldo: MOVEMENT I HEAR
REPUBLICANS IF YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN YOU ARE A RACIST,
DANA.
I HEAR THAT THAT'S HOW FAR
IT HAS GOTTEN IN THIS ERA IN
WHICH WE --
>> Dana: THAT'S WHY IT'S
REFRESHING TO HAVE SOMEBODY
LIKE WHOOPI GOLDBERG WHO
CONSISTENTLY POINTS THAT OUT
AS BEING FAULTY.
SHE SPEAKS FROM -- WELL, SHE
IS PASSIONATE ABOUT FROM
WHICH SHE SPEAKS THE.
BUT ALSO SPEAKS FROM
POSITION OF SOMEBODY WHO HAS
BEEN TARGETED IN THE PAST BY
OTHERS.
SO I THINK SHE IS A GOOD
COUNTER.
BUT THE THING ABOUT SOMEBODY
LIKE DEBRA MESSING IS THAT
THEY LEARN NOTHING.
EVERY TIME THEY DO SOMETHING
LIKE THIS, IT IS LIKE WHEN
PACMAN GOES AROUND AND HE
EATS ONE OF THE LITTLE
FRUITS.
IT STRENGTHENS PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
SO IF THEY WOULD JUST BE
QUIET, BRIAN BRIAN NOW WE
DON'T PLAY PACMAN ANYMORE I
WILL TALK ABOUT THAT MORE IN
THE BREAK.
>> Geraldo: DEFINITELY
QUALITY FOR THE BREAK.
>> Brian: ONE THING I WOULD
LOVE TO BRING UP STEVEN ROSS
TOO PAYING THE PRICE OWNS
HUDSON YARDS.
GOING TO MOVE THEIR FASHION
SHOW OUT BECAUSE HE HAD THE
AUDACITY TO HAVE A
FUNDRAISER IN THE HAMPTONS
WHICH SOME PEOPLE I KNOW
WENT TO.
>> Geraldo: I CAN'T IMAGINE
WHO HE IS SPEAKING.